parler de christophe dettinger il va pas
être christophe dettinger l'ancien
boxeur professionnel maintenant il est
champion de france il était champion
france des lourds légers en 2007-2008
alors on va revoir la vidéo qui l'a fait
connaître malgré lui il nous a accordé
une interview christophe dettinger vous
avez vous dire ce que vous en pensez
donc il avait été filmé en train de
boxer vous le savez des forces de
l'ordre est ce que voulait revoir
l'image
oui non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est bon alors c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal à revoir ces images un mineur à
tous pour être joués demander si vous
voulez les revoir ou pas donc il s'est
ensuite rendu à la police après avoir
fait une vidéo de mea culpa
il nous a donc accordé une interview
christophe dettinger il explique dans
cette vidéo
pourquoi il a choisi de s'exprimer dans
balances ton post regardez moi les gens
et ma famille mes amis mon entourage et
gens qui ont pu le côtoyer quelques
instants dans savent très bien que c'est
pas moi fait passer de personnes qui
sont médiatisés le savons maintenant à
des millions de personnes ont eu en vue
ont vu les infos qu'est ce qu'ils en
pensent eux c'est pour ça que je suis
aujourd'hui aux cages points voilà donc
il il a voulu s'exprimer alors eric
naulleau vous avez souhaité lui poser
une question
par l'intermédiaire de notre journaliste
vous avez dit j'aimerais comprendre ce
qui s'est passé précisé bon pour qu'il
arrive à un tel acte de violence mais
moi j'aurais bien aimé quand on voit
toutes les images parce qu'il y en a
d'autres encore plus choquant c'est que
la bande à un moment il ya une scène de
lynchage où ils s'acharnent à coude sont
là on a dit maja soir à domicile à terre
avec l'aide d'autres personnes
écoutez le c'est le problème c'est que
quand je vois que la première séquence
je me dis le type pète les plombs ça
arrive à tout le monde bon voilà la
deuxième séquence ci est à terre dont
j'aurais bien voulu oui savoir qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans sa tête
au delà et frottez eelv aurait pas là ce
jour là
c'était trop c'était pas des casseurs
quitter lyon fait des gens du peuple et
pas de casseurs il n'y a pas de voyous y
avait rien on s'est tous fait gazer on
s'est fait matraquer j'ai vu cette
violence policière
cette violence qui a été extrême tout le
monde se faire matraquer
et si une personne on se